ahora vamos a explorar la primera ley de
la termodinámica y antes incluso de que
hablemos de la primera ley de la
termodinámica algunos de ustedes se
pueden estar preguntando bueno que es la
termodinámica pues bien podemos darnos
una idea si analizamos las raíces de
esta palabra tenemos termo que significa
calor y dinámica las propiedades del
calor cómo se mueve cómo se comporta el
calor y eso es más o menos lo que es la
termodinámica se trata del estudio del
calor y la temperatura y cómo se
relacionan con la energía y el trabajo y
cómo las diferentes formas de energía
pueden ser transformadas de una forma a
otra y eso es realmente el corazón de la
primera ley de la termodinámica que
vimos en el vídeo sobre introducción a
la energía y la primera ley de la
termodinámica nos dice que la energía
esto es muy importante así que voy a
escribirlo la energía no se crea ni
se destruye
no se crea
ni
sé
destruye
solo se puede transformar de una forma a
otra
solo
puede
transformar
de una forma
ah
otra
o podría ser transferida pero no va a
poder ser creada o destruida y quiero
que realmente comprendas esto y vamos a
mirar un montón de ejemplos y pensar
cuál es la energía que estamos
observando o que estamos viendo en un
sistema y luego pensar de dónde viene
esa energía darnos cuenta de que no está
saliendo de la nada que no está
desapareciendo y que no está siendo
destruida tampoco
vamos a empezar con este ejemplo de un
foco o bombilla y te invito a pausar el
vídeo y que pienses en las formas de
energía que podemos ver aquí y luego
pensar de dónde está viniendo esa
energía y a dónde se va
bueno la forma más obvia de energía que
podemos ver aquí y esta es la función
principal de un foco es la energía
radiante vemos las ondas
electromagnéticas la luz siendo emitida
desde el foco ésta es la energía
radiante
energía
y esa energía radiante se debe al calor
que se genera en este filamento
conforman los electrones pasan a través
del filamento se genera calor así que
tenemos energía térmica energía
térmica pero de dónde vienen esta
energía radiante y esta energía térmica
una vez más la primera ley de la
termodinámica nos dice no está siendo
creada de la nada debe ser transformada
o transferida desde algún lugar bueno te
acaba de dar una pista esta energía
térmica se debe a los electrones que se
mueven a través del filamento se están
moviendo a través del filamento que
presenta cierta resistencia y eso genera
calor así que los electrones se mueven a
través de este filamento y conforme se
mueven a través de esa resistencia
generan calor así que también tenemos
energía cinética de los electrones voy a
escribir s para abreviar la energía
cinética de los electrones y de dónde
viene esta energía cinética pues viene
de la energía potencial probablemente
esto esté conectado a una toma de
corriente o un enchufe de algún tipo
permítanme dibujar una toma de corriente
por aquí voy a dibujar un enchufe por
aquí
y si este es el enchufe eléctrico de tu
casa existe un potencial electrostático
entre estas dos terminales y así cuando
haces una conexión los electrones son
capaces de moverse y vamos a entrar en
detalles de la corriente alterna y
directa en el futuro pero hay un
potencial electrostático desde este
punto hasta este punto suponiendo que es
la dirección en la que los electrones
van y es la energía potencial la que
convertimos a la energía cinética de los
electrones que se encuentran en la forma
de una corriente eléctrica y luego eso
es transformado en energía térmica y en
energía radiante ahora bien qué pasa
después digamos que desenchufar el foco
y la luz se apaga qué pasa con toda esa
energía está ahí todavía bueno la
energía térmica se va a continuar
disipando a través del sistema y esto
sería un sistema abierto que consiste en
el aire dentro del foco no se puede ver
bien el foco pero se ve algo
el aire va a calentarse y luego va a
calentar el vidrio que está alrededor y
eso va a calentar el aire circundante
por lo tanto la energía térmica va a ser
transferida y la energía radiante se va
a mover hacia el exterior y podría ser
convertida en otras formas de energía
muy probablemente en energía térmica ya
que probablemente va a calentar otras
cosas
bueno qué pasa con una mesa de billar si
golpeó una bola de billar qué va a
ocurrir con esa energía pues algo de esa
energía podría estar yendo a golpear la
siguiente bola que podría ir a golpear
la siguiente bola pero como todos
sabemos si alguna vez has jugado billar
en algún momento se van a detener
entonces qué pasó con toda esa energía
bueno mientras estaban rodando hubo
cierta resistencia del aire por lo que
están chocando contra las moléculas de
aire y se genera fricción con el aire y
esa energía va a ser esencialmente
convertida en calor y una tendencia que
vas a ver con mucha frecuencia es que
conforme un sistema progresa una gran
parte de la energía tiende a convertirse
en calor en lugar de hacer algún trabajo
útil por lo que vamos a tener que
conforme las bolas de billar se mueven
está la fricción con el aire por lo que
una parte de esa energía cinética va a
ser convertida en energía térmica
también va a haber fricción con el
fieltro de la mesa y esa fricción
implica que vas a tener moléculas
frotándose unas contra otras eso también
va a ser convertido en calor y debido a
que la energía cinética se agotó y se
sigue agotando debido a la fricción lo
que está esencialmente convirtiendo la
energía cinética en energía térmica con
el tiempo ya no habrá más energía
cinética
ahora qué pasa con este levantador de
pesas está usando la energía química en
el atp que se encuentra en sus músculos
que se convierte en energía cinética que
mueve sus músculos que mueven esta pesa
pero una vez que está en esta posición
que pasa con toda esa energía bueno una
gran parte de esa energía ahora se está
almacenando como energía potencial
energía
potencial
tiene esta gran pesa sobre su cabeza y
sí en soltar a esa pesa esta simplemente
se caería yo no recomendaría que hiciera
eso la pesa caería bastante rápido y
entonces ahora una gran parte de la
energía ha sido almacenada como energía
potencial pero también se habría
generado calor sus músculos habrían
generado calor incluso el acto de mover
la pesa por el aire va a generar algo de
calor en el aire algo de fricción con el
aire y quiero que veas que esta energía
no está saliendo de la nada se está
convirtiendo de una forma u otra está
siendo transferida de una parte del
sistema a otra ahora podemos ver estos
ejemplos aquí lo mismo ocurre con el
corredor su energía química está
permitiendo que sus músculos se muevan y
eso se transforma en energía cinética
para todo su cuerpo su cuerpo se está
moviendo pero en algún momento se
detiene y entonces a dónde se va toda
esa energía bueno una parte de la
energía será calor en su cuerpo que está
siendo disipada en el aire y también
cuando estaba corriendo hubo contacto
con el suelo eso va a hacer que las
moléculas de la tierra vibren un poco
algo de esta vibración será transferida
como sonido que es el movimiento de
partículas de aire moviéndose a través
del aire y gran parte de esa energía
será calor vamos a ver eso una y otra y
otra vez
ahora vamos con el clavadista aquí
arriba tenemos principalmente energía
potencial que después se convierte en
energía cinética conforme va cayendo
hacia el agua pero qué sucede una vez
que cae dentro del agua bueno entonces
esa energía va a ser transferida al agua
y vamos a tener estas ondas en el agua
que se alejan y también se aumentará la
fricción aunque bueno en realidad
habríamos tenido fricción mientras que
allá por el aire por lo que se habría
generado un poco de calor y habría
habido también un poco de calor generado
por la fricción con el agua normalmente
no pensamos que haya fricción con el
agua pero hay algo de fricción con el
agua y también están estas ondas hay una
gran energía cinética en el agua que
está siendo transferida hacia afuera
desde donde el clavadista entro al agua
y podría seguir y seguir aquí hay
energía potencial química del
combustible
ocurriendo una combustión y esa energía
es convertida en energía térmica y la
energía radiante que asociamos con el
fuego y eso no desaparece la energía
radiante solo sigue irradiando hacia el
exterior tal vez podría calentar algo y
la energía térmica simplemente se
disipará hacia afuera y calentará las
cosas a su alrededor
lo mismo con este rayo empieza con el
potencial electro estático donde la
parte inferior de las nubes es más
negativa y el suelo es positivo y en
algún momento esa energía potencial se
convierte en energía cinética conforme
se va a la transferencia de electrones a
través del aire y luego eso se convierte
en calor y energía radiante así que el
objetivo principal de este vídeo es que
sin importar el ejemplo en que nos
fijemos si lo analizas cuidadosamente y
te invito a hacer esto en tu día a día
la energía no se genera por arte de
magia simplemente está siendo convertida
de una forma a otra